hello hello hi what's your name Valerio
Valerio every probable area Italy Italy
lovely
do you live here yes what do you do here
Valerio I'm a logistical manager I can't
Amazon fire oh I hate will give you the
manager
I wanna get cheated on Morgan all over
again I loved when you were talking to
Morgan Freeman's penis
that's what the girl was when you're
bending down so sorry valaria we're back
obligatory Valeria's okay so I'm here
tonight to surprise my beautiful wife
Alma Alma yeah see she actually in the
audience tonight
Oh without AA you short wave like you're
so I feel I got it it's exactly God no
you're gonna go up Alma's still here
optical flare it was a nice surprise oh
yes of course
okay she's pregnant Oh our first baby oh
we don't know yet the gender of the baby
because I really want wait untii the
baby's bottom quarter but she really
want to know as soon as possible
oh yes so the doctor wrote on this piece
of paper or gender of the baby oh and I
say to her we will open in a special
occasion so because she loves you and
your show I believe that tonight is the
best Oh may I open yes
[Applause]
okay get it to Larry back Larry
[Applause]
okay here we go so Alma dama
you ready it will be a boy or a girl
yeah what you're calling it Wayne here
we go here we go the babies he's a girl
[Applause]
[Music]